a deal to provide more money to small
businesses as close to being clinched
while some Americans took to the streets
to protest stay-at-home orders a new
poll shows that a majority fear lifting
restrictions too early from Airlines to
tech many S&P 500 companies are expected
to report earnings this week hi I'm
Jason Bellini with the latest reporting
on the coronavirus crisis from The Wall
Street Journal I think we were getting
close to a deal could happen a new
rescue package for small businesses
could pass early this week
last month's 350 billion dollar fund to
help small businesses quickly ran out as
millions of Americans lost jobs we
report that a new stimulus package is
likely to infuse an additional three
hundred and ten billion dollars into the
small business program the agreement is
also expected to include 75 billion
dollars for hospitals and 25 billion
dollars to expand testing for the virus
nationwide reported coronavirus deaths
have now topped 40,000 in the US the
country has the world's highest number
of cases though the pandemic has shown
signs of easing in some states over the
weekend Americans worried about their
economic prospects demonstrated against
stayed home orders in Ohio Colorado and
Wisconsin hundreds of people rallied
outside while some in Maryland drove
their cars in protests however according
to a new poll conducted by The Wall
Street Journal and NBC News nearly 60%
of Americans say they're concerned their
country would loosen restrictions too
quickly almost three-quarters of
respondents also worried about catching
the virus themselves that's a jump from
about half last month this week
companies including Netflix Delta and
coca-cola are scheduled to report
earnings for the first three months of
2020 listed attempt of S&P companies
have reported results so far this
earnings season and profits have fallen
almost 15 percent but some companies are
expected to benefit from people
worldwide staying home the video
streaming company Netflix will report
earnings on Tuesday
big tech stocks are charging to new
heights and propelling a stock market
rebounds